tu ainda mais fino conectar o jogador
fez gol
se quiserem o como evitar o jogador fez
gol comentem e deixei muito mas se
tivermos mais de 50 mil comentários e
pedir um jogador testou por 50 mil eu
vou fazer um óptimo de sua vida de quem
fala andar sejam muito bem vindos
ele é mais um dia aqui no brasil mais um
dia de rock in rio muita emoção muita
coisa boa acontecendo ali muita música
muito bom sério tudo que padura dito que
culmina no quadro olha lá o hino então
está tudo bem está tudo bem em 2008 de
fazer é melhor não e há pouco tempo saiu
conectar um jogador do al certo já está
com 2 milhões muito mais mesmo obrigado
pessoal por todo o apoio e eu encontrei
agora uma coisa elemento que vocês
também partilharam muito lá no twitter
options o meu fez um som limpo idosos de
viagem é vaca frango como evitar um
jogador bom basicamente são idosos
dirigir os meus vídeos de conectar um
jogador do outro uma compilação pois o
que eu vou fazer é eu ia exigir aos
idosos deve agir
ao conectar um jogador do al é eu acho
que é uma coisa estranha porque nunca vi
um idoso e os meninos porque ela deve
pensar nesse caso é bom ou então se ela
gosta do tipo não sair até agora só
preciso colocar aqui câmara né isso que
na última janela de rua não janela de
rua o homem que vai estar em baixo o que
a gente queria o fla é brutal o que
estão a fazer é muito bom mesmo porque
vai parecer que embora ó hoje nós vamos
apresentar mais um pouco o português
para vocês rodada da premier league onde
a taxa às transações nos as suas
presenças de deus
[Música]
i generosa 2005 e de lá ir muito bem
isso para espalhar ea todos os meses
dizem que o homem de cabelos em um único
pé eles assistam à inteligência de graça
e rob lowe brutal mesmo sair e deixar em
frente à forçado pela mas há quem rompe
[Música]
o meu ok eu cheguei muito no meu
mundinho regime distraídos não só de
história dessa
então o deus é filha de um patinho nada
não né não
e já estão antigas episódio eu acho que
é o 2
não beijo william galston estágio num só
o pai noel que papai noel não passaram
[Música]
[Aplausos]
da fase em que anunciou que não saibamos
porrada tirar mar cadeiras
a inapal é e único marxista a pior
enchente
eu acho que assim como eu não acho que
não sou muito chato espaço delimitado no
mapa nada disso vai ser o episódio isso
vai ser lá eo fugiram
e essa bomba foi bem grave muito
engraçado eu só espero que portugal
aí já não lembrava de sua igreja
aí sinto 5 bilhões
ae
milton adquirir aborto é um mesmo clube
distribuiu 18 min
eu tive que comprar outro veja só como
ficou o estudo janeiro no brasil
[Música]
eu eo ppi e sozinho na grande área e boa
casa assim anúncio da equipe frente joga
o livro tóquio onde ela passa do toca na
casa de uma pessoa além do leite jogou
uma copa
isso é uma perda é a paciência dele
depois da revolta dele essas eu nunca
pensei que só com este dado que mostrou
se dividido difícil eu me lembro quando
era criança eu tirava a dizer na cara
pulou em cima vieram de outro ditado
muito gosta de fazer um brutal como
evitar os dólares bois aí como é que
está tudo bem comigo nunca pensei que um
jogo até o fim dessa gente ganhar a liga
não faria um salto leva a pôr em ação do
cortado do mundial
miguel e me perguntei muito real e as
urubah são elas urbanos urbana ou no
começo o resultado folgado o daquele faz
várias coisas no youtube que esse namoro
com todos ao amarrar esses com trechos
no caso mais famosa do canal dele como a
motor novo e já tem seis episódios que a
reunião já que pega o guarani o sucesso
isso é bom porque estão aqui
coisa dessas coisas chama a atenção que
a gente hoje mas ele porque isso aí é
verdade que a coisa tá muito só não
gostar suas brincadeiras monte de coisas
tem gente gritando mandando o outro uma
casa linda mas num dia de natal
quem é que é o quesito alguém alguma vez
na vida a gente se identifica semana de
setembro já tudo a vitória em oito muito
espontâneo e brincadeiras que sacanagem
minha cabeça do outro a conclusão disso
excesso e que em caso de semana cuidado
vai falar pra mim é louco
portugal visita na casa de vovó sua casa
está aberta a isso vai dar
aí nós vamos sacar ao dade eu faço como
evitar um idoso na hora só vai lá pra
casa só aí não quero que cada episódio
tem que aumentar tipo sempre comida
rodal
eu pretendo certo tempo porque é muito
lenta embora agora vai pegar completa
família dela está se concentrando a
filha de luiza brunet não faria
gostei da rússia não conheço
obrigado obrigado eu sei que está
fazendo o maior sucesso em portugal com
um abraço aí também já que o gasto caiu
no brasil já tocava rock acabou né
bom pessoal foi esta reação meu brutal
mesmo portal que nunca pensei que toda a
gente durar esse tipo deveria debater e
idosos mesmo que eu pensei que eles
viviam sempre isto como uma uma
palhaçada uma coisa fora um pouco do
mundo deus mas acho que não não gosto e
não gosto é gosto dele não ninguém
tudo ainda vai ser conectar o jogador se
lesionou aos quiseram comentar 2001
quando você quiser em o como evitar o
uso do facebook comentem e deixa muito
light estiveram os mais de 50 mil
comentários a pedir um jogador fechou
aos 50 mil eu vou fazer eu quando chegar
a portugal que eu vou fazer
então é isso vamos ficar porque este
vídeo muito obrigado aí o pessoal da
janela da rua foi brutal vídeo mesmo um
grande abraço pra vocês já sabem o
quanto quiserem avançar em casa lá em
portugal aparece o mar que eu abri a
porta abriu a porta que o filme como
evitar um idoso lá e não sair agora nós
vamos ter que fazer coisas aqui no rock
meu e não é isso vamos mesmo fazer muita
coisa muita coisa houve muitas lojas não
cita o hertha eo time e aí pessoal fique
bem é se aproximar